Để định trước của bởi đầu xương kinh đỉnh của T-MTV tại MSI hàng hành hú trong 20 năm,
ai sẽ là mì biết tiếp tra sự viên quan trình đầu trường của T-MTV.
Sơ chận chính thẳng ba khô chức mily bí liên gà mình,
đưa thủ tiếp theo của T-MTV đừng kiếm vô đức MSI hàng hành hú trong 20 năm,
một trong những ứng cử viên sẵn xa trong hội vô định lên này.
Nhưng T-MTV cũng không cạnh kạnh khi lên tiếp dành chính thẳng trong các trận gần đây với phong bộ cự kỳ bùng trái.
Họ đang tây hiện hi mong của vô chiu S-KT trong thời gian kia đừng cào,
trong rất chử đại dân dí và dành lại vinh quan đã mất sau gần một tập kỳ h.
Chẳng đông xe xin xa vào bệ dương em người thống bệnh,
anh em fán hai đổi hãy chuẩn bị sáng sàng để gồm vũ cho trận đối đầu chú vươi này,